hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within I'm
continuing straight on from where I left
off trying to find my lost lads and a
pile of skulls and body parts oh I'm
sure they're fine
yeah well what could have happened to
them naked boy well I don't know what to
say but I still see Joe Joe's little
thing over there there's no way out of
here wait a minute what's going on wait
a minute now wait a minute now
wait there's no way out of here
what's that is that a thing can't seem
to go that way what's going on wait a
minute are they in here I think it's
under the pile of bodies why is gonna be
stuck here in perpetuity oh did I get a
bug oh I got a bug didn't I what's going
on I thought it was weird because when I
jumped in the holism oh that wasn't
there before
oh you sassy sue oh you're also sassy
you think you're gonna mess with me huh
don't you know exactly how Pro I am
let's make sure I'm reloaded here good
good that guy doesn't seem to be too
happy about my situation oh I got the
guy behind you
[Applause]
looks like I've improved a bit I don't
even need to burn him now I'm gonna be
just fine without Bert excuse me while I
scoot your body around on the things and
impale you on one of the rebar that's
poking its way through the ground I was
a bit more complicated than I would have
expected a dead body do it oh that's an
oil drop dead body to understand so well
these guys look thoroughly dead at least
they're having a good time
Hey okay your dead mom gearbox if I
could craft up some stuff that I could
use I would be very Oh swing in the
wrong room also I just saw the trailer
for five nights at Freddy's 2 it's the
other trailers out games not out yet but
the trailer is there you see I used to
check it out it's on Scott Cawthon or
however say his name Cal thorn his
YouTube channel
I'm a provided link in the description
link in the description below Jojo hey
Jojo Mojo Jojo Mojo Jojo Jojo Jojo my
main man where's you and Nicole you guys
okay guess that brought all this is a
notion applaud why did I go in the ocean
the blood really hard to see anything
maybe there's a secret down here give me
give me secret secret secret secret
secrets secrets secrets arm so fun
secret circuits heard adamak you'll see
too many things yes brain juice oh come
on there's got to be more than that
thank you
oh come on he's doing good I keep
thinking I see things when I turn around
but then they just disappear on me
was there something up here maybe this
was the secret oh there's more stuff up
here than there was underneath there
how's that fair huh do I just do this on
a dare
maybe I should crawl back to my lair
female horses a mare leader of a town as
a mayor as well but their smell
different
hey Sookie okay these guys are dead just
still having a good time I'll take this
stuff thank you thank you thank you okay
still haven't found any more map puzzle
pieces it seems to be extremely lost in
this what was that oh that was just a
door behind me crows anything dodo okay
I'll burn you you look like your butt
yeah I thought so I suspected as much
are you gonna give me an item whoo hey
hello what's gonna Hey oh where you
gonna go oh you need to burn too
sorry you get burnt and then I reload
and you give me your goodies you weirdly
spaz and read as you burnt to death okay
no items for me
oh hello Jojo don't shoot me I know
you're just hacking me earlier but don't
shoot me again Sebastian I thought you
said Seabiscuit
no just tired about horses with okay all
right you're sorry Jojo did I shoot you
fine explode head heads blows there we
go oh don't bring them over here there
goes oh that was you're gonna do there's
no way to melee things to death in this
game it's stupid I got just a few bumps
I'm about to die I can't you heal me
buddy I'm healing you you heal me come
on rub my back I'll rub yours no so I
can't go this way I'm sure you would
have been fine but because I I just will
completely stop mailing thing because
there's no point in it why isn't there
an alternative I have a knife okay what
am I supposed to do here hey Jojo what's
going on just going like the door's
locked from the other side Sebastian if
we can lift this enough for Kidman to go
under and open it from the other side oh
yeah all right we're counting on you
don't get cut in half
also JoJo's crazy by the way did I
mention that Jojo little bit crazy looks
like me a little bit crazy okay bye okay
then
goddamn let's get going my health I just
am not good at it is that slowly
recovering to the midpoint there oh hi
thanks okay I thought that was gonna be
a bit more disastrous than it was
whenever everything turned out better
than expected I see your bra oh you're
just in the water I guess I was weird
it's not a what t-shirt contest game
lady alright yeah I'm slowly recovering
else but that doesn't mean it's good I'm
glad you're both alright job
why would they catch you instead of just
killing you maybe he didn't see me as a
threat he Rubick oh that's bad
Oh God okay then thank you I'm still
getting a little bit of bugs from
turning the aspect ratio the part of
those doors
yeah those doors those lovely lovely
doors is there anything over here
aha I knew it oh come on okay all right
fine
this game is leading me in directions
that I don't want it to go
I guess this chapters just never gonna
end so whoa detective Sebastian Caston
Ellison detective mere Hansen joyfully
requests the pleasure of your company at
the wedding celebration Saturday 17th of
September 2005 at half-past twelve at
the veranda hotel crimson City a
reception to follow I'm sure that went
beautifully yeah I know I know I know
I'm exploring my past the nurse is
probably Mira something bad happened
you're uncomfortably close okay bye I'm
just gonna just gonna go sit in this
chair for a little bit and think about
my life even though I don't have a lot
of brain juice like I just got a whole
bunch after going through the waiver oh
wait those wrists I just noticed they
have like medicine things on trend
recovery oh oh I didn't even see that
one before that would have been way
better oh why didn't I do that I'm such
a ding ding dad might get a single
damage up oh why didn't I get a damage
multiplier man if I was gonna help out
my per bullet damage why didn't I do
that one
I don't think logically when I'm in a
horror situation how it's actually in a
horror movie I would not do well I don't
think I have any more keys it has not
been long enough for me to get around
anything so I don't think I have needed
thanks lady
you know since you're a nurse maybe you
could heal me up a little bit
oh you're a nurse too doctor a plea err
oh I see so you're no good at all okay
someone sounds unhappy why is there
floating blood gah Buell's in the air Oh
finally I get a bottle that I can
distract someone with okay before I go
down into the depths oh I'm gonna see
what's going on over here unless I'm
supposed to go down in the depths first
and that's the way I would normally go
I'm gonna go down in the depths first
because that's what seems the most
inviting to me as a person oh god more
blood more giblets okay you almost got
me there oh hey hey whoa what you gonna
do and burn you up cuz there's oh oh I
thought I'm out really whoa that's what
I need to do oh my gosh Clark a judgment
how dare you mother okay I think he
might be dead but maybe not you never
know let's try this to finish him off
chunk that was uncomfortably close not
exactly where I wanted it to go but
let's see where this one oh this goes on
the other side of the way where all the
boxes we're blocking it up okay okay
alright alright alright alright alright
let's see what you go for don't be booby
trapped
hey let me down what do we do
it's booby-trapped how about i disarm it
I see it's booby-trapped tonight I can't
survive this I there's anything good
inside it maybe there's not if I shoot
it nope
okay well I'm gonna die fun no no maybe
I just got to open it a bit more to be
able to do it that seems like a really
bad train logic is that really a bomb oh
god it is oh there we go
God why wouldn't you disturb the runaway
I obviously know why is that one easy to
use that I would love to I've got all
these craft ease that I can't use kids I
got nothing to use it on okay I can't
clear this de bris so I got to go back
down I would love to be able to use that
I would love to that would be like my
top priority in the usage meter of my
life I would love to but sadly you do
not allow me to whoa
what is it Oh a bottle oh that would be
nice oh well yeah I don't know where
that went
oh that's right I switched to my gun
before I can hit him with a bottle I'm
gonna keep this bottle bullets thank you
box of bullets don't go near more
bullets yes please thank you all right
so we're actually doing better on
bullets back to the pre-crisis era that
guy dead burn that guy I don't have any
matches left do I okay someone sounds
very alive
oh okay that's bad I'm gonna just don't
don't blow me up yet don't blow me up
yet don't blow me up yet come on come on
bruh there's no point in that how's the
most useless thing ever you don't see
nothing do you lady don't even try oh
yeah yeah totally where did I go oh it's
a mystery yeah you're so twitchy
why are you Twiggy huh oh come on come
on with that come on you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
I I must I must I must look very bad
room
I must look very bad at least my health
will slowly recovered to its baseline oh
why does that after use why does that
have to and why do you whoa whoa a
fitting end to a living nightmare
finally more matches I've been using
them a bit too liberally to be able to
do that so I guess I'm past the point of
hiding in these closets although there's
no point in hiding ever
I don't know even know why they had the
hiding we can't again after the first
part of the game like I didn't need to
hide there's no point in hiding hiding
does nothing unless it does and I'm just
not playing the game right but I don't
think maybe on the nightmare difficulty
when you have like nothing to use on
anyone you have to hide like all the
time I'm not gonna run back and burn
these sons of [ __ ] they're gonna be a
whole bunch of sons of [ __ ] running
my way Squishy's why this squishy that
looks fun let me just walk
I'm gonna burn you so good I cannot
sprint because I'm yeah of course of
course I get burnt in it oh that's bad
where am I going okay fire seems to work
yeah fire seems to do good I guess I
can't sprint while I'm below that level
because it won't let me okay she bashed
opened that real good allowed me to
progress a little farther good to know
that she can pop up anywhere these
impulses of blood okay jeez no no oh god
do I have to do target practice here
would you Rick great where are you oh
that that must be a bit of a burden let
me just ease your pain I'll catch it on
this side okay come on oh come on come
on there we go got ya you're lucky I
didn't shoot you you're lucky I want
these keys bad enough another med kit
good
I kind of need that but I'm gonna
hesitate on using that I had two physics
are you dad you better be dead I'm gonna
come on Vista oh that's bad
oh well at least nothing can follow me
at least I don't have to worry about
ever can I stomp on that guy please
well I'm just gonna smack him around a
little bit you know
Shaul moves boss go get up don't you
dare I'm gonna stick this right by you
chick stickers right by you if you ever
get a bad idea
oh that's flammable oh I see so I need
that uh dead bodies over there they're
gonna get up one of these is gonna get
up come on
you [ __ ] not you lady Oh
balonus paddy sucks so hard oh that I
went into a dead-end
[Music]
spot right to that right to that right
to it come on
like that oh you don't too bad oh that's
all I got
doodles more stacked on fire oh she's
still here oh she's still here isn't she
these aren't flammable
that's all locked up gonna have to burn
oh god if I had known I would have
burned it right away like you saw I
don't want to go in there probably God
that looks equally as bad as the place I
just laugh
oh come on how am I supposed to be able
to do anything torch yes torch please do
something
oh wow she did something to my face
thanks lady
I got her in the trap why didn't it get
to her that's a shame
house is a little too slow I guess what
I'm supposed to do is I'm supposed to
know that was the only way to going that
it would be able to get her so I'm
assuming I need to okay so I know what I
need to do I think I need to get her
down into that pit and then drop her
down that's what's gonna finish her off
maybe I don't know if that's absolutely
true but it's most likely probably true
which is almost just as good as being
absolutely true okay so here we go it's
a bit of a complicated situation I'm
gonna be able to do so I need to burn
her first to be able to like be sure and
then I need her to come out of a body
so if I go down there then she will be
able to pop out of the body down there
oh damn it
so if she pops out at a time lady hey
hey hey Bern Bern why is that fair
that's not fair I would like to pick to
submit to the court that's not
okay so I need to go another way now so
I guess this way is good enough for me
oh hey burner in that body I guess
that's gonna help something I don't know
maybe come on mouth great little pull
expeditions this step [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
it's not gonna work
I'm not gonna be able to kill her you
need to get into the fire do not take a
braise higher dog dagger prize IRA are
you kidding me
god damn you damn you to hell just jump
down there I'm down here now what you
gonna do you're gonna come after me lady
yeah come on
cozy down here cozy down here in the
guts a pal
oh she has to go through every single
body
I gotta burn all the bodies first I did
not know that oh I thought she was in
front of me talking to burn all the
bodies huh that's gonna be easy enough
come on the Sprint system let's sprint
system is literally the worst
whoo-whoo runs four seconds and gets out
of breath it needs to take a breather oh
that's sad it's not fair that is the
stupidest thing ever okay so now that I
know what I need to do it's gonna be a
little bit easier so what I need to do
is I need to burn the bodies first
that's primary thing I need to do that's
first and foremost I need to burn all
the bodies do the first one
oh so I'm gonna burn you it burnt thank
you
maybe I just need to burn her enough
sorry did you wanna
I see you don't
oh it's it hurts you know are you gonna
come out of this one next huh probably
No
yeah
okay I'm gonna be very conscious about
my sprint this time this is getting a
little little bit aggravating where's
this go
this leads down there she not by me
whoa whoa whoa whoa there Nessie whoa
okay so I'm gonna use the second barrel
burn her up as she goes by here come on
this way
hi lady which way you go going that way
bye mommy there we go right this no
match this really matches the exact same
the exact thing that I would need at
this moment so now she's gonna get a
body somewhere nearby I mean I guess I
might as well just burn the bodies here
I'd be helpful throw those in the pit
coming up this way
whoa all the way all the way other
well she is very persistent right now do
not take a breather man you do your debt
added it had them in money book them
she has no other bodies to go through
she will die
she burned up in that one I don't have
anything to burn up this one do I whoa
what I did
oh so I did just need to burn her a
bunch I didn't okay and that would have
done that well there you have it
hi hurry I did it so I did it that was
actually challenging so I guess I can
pat myself on the back and move forward
with my life
thank you where's Jojo where's Jojo
Nicole Oh Jonah cold and the latest
sitcom from Resident Evil 4 the evil
within and the creators of the evil
within Resident Evil okay oh this looks
like a thing for a lot of people in it
[Music]
subjects case history cites
developmental delays indicates issues
signs of synesthesia reported genealogy
suggests increases septa bility to
external stimuli pattern adaptiveness
okay what I've been searching for all
these years is that Leslie there can be
no mistake this one has
compatible that's lovely
oh whoa whoa whoa holy hell that's a big
brain that was son okay
oh really I'm gonna throw a grenade at
you whoa whoa all right
grenades out have fun have fun its
fireworks fourth of July
okay did not mean to press Evan but hey
you missed one
oh no are you oh no oh it's so sad for
you
that blow of your head no I'm gonna
unplug you oh oh oh god oh god oh god no
oh yeah so I need to unplug him that's
the thing yep
okay that's another down so I just need
to knock you over
barely my grenade technique was not good
enough I need to actually literally
unplug these guys
smile all my explosion did forcibly
unplug to the gas
okay then yeah finally I'd be chapter
five okay Tommen and this one here it's
almost 30 minutes to make up for the
little extra in the last episode give me
a chance to make more episodes because
I'm going back to Cincinnati real soon
so thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for videos that
I've done in the past and other series
that have been great and awesome that
I've done over the two and a half years
I've done YouTube and thanks again
everybody for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]
I wonder died